Okay, so
yesterday Donald Trump had had a rally indoors
at a megachurch in Arizona.
You might be wondering.
Wait a second, Eric.
Let me check my notes.
Arizona, Arizona is one of the worst case
growth Corona virus hot spots in the world.
Never mind the country does that.
Is that the right place to have a big indoor
rally?
And you would be right to ask that question.
Arizona is the state indeed with the largest
percentage case increase in the last week
or so, cases up forty eight percent in the
last eight days.
In Arizona, cases just spiking hugely.
So what does the president do?
He holds a rally indoors at a huge church
in Arizona.
Now, before we even go further, people have
been e-mailing me saying how can a church
hold a campaign event?
Churches are given nonprofit tax exempt status
in exchange for not doing politics.
Churches aren't allowed to do politics.
And here they are hosting a Trump campaign
event.
And I agree.
I don't know what to tell you.
I mean, these root what we do know is that
the rules against churches doing politics
are rarely enforced.
It is very rare that a church will actually
be punished for doing politics, despite churches
doing politics, being banned.
So I just don't have an answer.
It says we have no accountability.
Now, faced with questions about the the the
the prudence, prudence, prudence, and I'm
not sure, based on the questions about the
wisdom of doing this rally in Arizona, given
that cases are exploding in Arizona.
The CFO of Dream City Church, this was held
at Dream City Church in Dream City Church,
has a CFO named Brendan Zastrow.
They posted a video saying, we've installed
a new air filtration system, by the way, manufactured
by one of our congregants, and it kills ninety
nine point nine percent of Corona virus.
Now, health experts and anybody with common
sense immediately said that's not true.
That's an absurd claim to make.
Arizona State University scientists said it's
an absurd claim to make.
Quote, Matthew, Scotch warned, quote, This
is absurd and will not protect you.
But here's the church saying that this is
the situation.
They've got a great air filtration system
that will kill Corona virus.
Take a look.
It covered 19 here, Drew City Church, where
the first church in the nation, too.
Yeah.
We've got we've installed Clean Air AXP.
We have a local Arizona company.
It was technology developed by some members
of our church.
And we've installed these units and it kills
ninety nine point nine percent of Cauvin within
10 minutes from independent testing.
Is that ionization?
The mine is Iveson.
Its ionization of the air and it takes particulate
salary.
And Kovik cannot live in that environment.
So when you come into our auditorium, ninety
nine percent of it is gone.
If it was there in the first place, so you
can know when you come here, you'll be safe
and protected.
Thank God for great technology and thank God
for being proactive.
Hey, man.
Bless you guys.
I like how it's not ionization.
It's ionization.
Ionization.
But it's all B.S.. Pronounce it however you
want.
It's all B.S..
Now, even if it were true that their ionization
system kills the virus in some abstract way,
if I'm standing right next to somebody and
they don't have a mask and I don't have a
mask, an air filtration system in the ceiling
or in the.
Walls is not actually going to protect me
from the people that are right next to me
without masks.
So it's wildly irresponsible.
It's absurd.
And then there's the the rally itself, which
was a complete and total farcical Gong Show.
Trump was visibly sweaty and disheveled the
entire time, slurring badly, brought students
up to speak during the event who were used
as pathetic and horrible political props.
Everything about it was horrible.
Trump, again, going with this racist Cung
flu name for Corona virus, firing up the crowd
with it.
Imagine cheering for this.
Take a look.
We've covered Devin Otis said the other night.
Did anybody see my speech the other night?
On Saturday night?
So what I said the other night, there's never
been anything with have so many names, I could
give you 19 or 20 names for that right.
To get all different names, Wolf, on Cohan's
was catching on Corona virus.
Right.
Kong flu.
Imagine 10 years from now thinking back and
saying, hey, remember when we went to that
rally?
And Trump said Cung flew, wasn't that great?
I mean, the place just absolutely loved it.
And that's actually I think that, you know,
the focus really should be on the number of
people that love this racist Kong flu stuff.
There's a lot of focus, understandably, on
the fact that the president is calling it
cung flu.
And there should be focus on that because
we shouldn't have a pleasant president who
does that?
There's no question about it.
But the audience was filled with people who
loved it.
That's the problem, though.
Trump saying it is a problem.
But if that immediately repelled people from
voting for him, we would say, OK, this is
a mad man, racist.
But nobody's voting for him.
The crowd loved it.
The audience, if you listen to that clip,
the audience was actually shouting out Kong
flu. Trump started saying Wu Han virus Chinese
buyers.
The crowd is yelling kung fu.
They want him to say it.
They're delighted by the racism of it all.
And I think that we want to distribute criticism
fairly.
And Trump saying this would not be nearly
the problem that it is were it not for the
fact that huge crowds of people absolutely
love it.
Now, here's Donald Trump in the same rally
yesterday, railing against vote by mail, saying,
listen, we voted in World War One and we voted
during World War Two.
Absentee ballots are fine.
Like I live in the White House.
And if I can't get to Florida or you live
wherever you live, you can't.
But you have to go through a process.
Some people just can't make it to a polling
station and they have good reason, but they
have to go through this process in order to
verify their identity.
People went to the polls and voted during
World War One.
They went to the polls and voted during World
War Two.
We can safely go to the polls and vote during
Kofod 19.
Now, what's funny about this or scary, is
that vote by mail is absentee ballots like
what word? Trump seems not to get it.
But what we're talking about is getting everybody
an absentee ballot.
It's just more of that.
Trump seems to imagine that if it's vote by
mail, it's different than the absentee ballots
that he used and that he says are OK.
And then Trump raises this issue about we
voted during World War One and World War Two.
The wars weren't contagious.
Pandemics and soldiers during those wars did
vote by mail.
So it's it's like a completely irrelevant
claim that Donald Trump is making.
Trump also, as is very common now during these
rallies, particularly ones that are happening
later in the day.
Trump having trouble speaking.
Here he is talking about America's flounders.
It's the same spirit that drove America's
founders.
And then here's Donald Trump.
Unable to say diploid, he says deplore instead.
And that's why when rioting and looting broke
out in our nation's capital, I quickly deplore.
I came in, I deployed the National Guard very
quickly.
So it was a truly irresponsible mess.
But the good news, like if there's anything
even slightly reassuring about what we're
seeing is that Trump's polling is suffering
very, very badly because of his handling of
coronavirus.
Trump is an incumbent president four months
out from his reelection camp, his his potential
reelection.
And most national polls have him polling in
the 30s.
OK.
That's a good sign in the sense that he can't
he's not as Teflon as he was once believed
to be on race relations, on Corona virus.
That new New York Times poll we talked about
earlier.
He's suffering badly.
So even though he was able to fill a room
with people cheering for King flew off, he
is suffering in the polls.
We just have to see whether it holds through
to November.
And that's why I was very cautious earlier
today when talking about polling.
The good news is maybe maybe he can't actually
get away with this stuff.